ازدحام مروري لا مثيل له في
عالم التجارة
ما لا يقل عن 160 سفينة تنتظر
العبور عبر قناة السويس
بعد محاولات فاشلة لإزاحة السفينة العملاقة
المحصورة عبرها.
تجريف الطين والرمل المحيطين ،
لكن حتى الآن لن تتزحزح السفينة ،
أوقفت سلطات القناة حركة المرور
عبر الممر المائي الحيوي يوم الخميس
عندما أصبح من الواضح أن خطة الإنقاذ
لن تكون سريعة
أو سهلة ، تمت صياغة فريق من خبراء الإنقاذ الهولندي والياباني
للمساعدة والتعبير عن الحذر مع مرور الوقت ،
فقد يستغرق
الأمر من أيام إلى أسابيع اعتمادًا
على ما تصادفه ،
عليك أن تدرك أن المعدات
التي تحتاجها بالطبع ليست قريبة جدًا
من 12 بالمائة من حجم التجارة العالمية.
من خلال القناة بشكل طبيعي
وعادة ما تتعامل مع ما يعادل
10 مليارات دولار يوميًا في
خبراء صناعة الشحن إذا
لم يتم حل الموقف قريبًا.
هنا يمكن أن يكون له تأثير كبير على
أسعار الشحن والحاويات في سوق النفط
مما يؤدي إلى ارتفاع تكلفة البضائع
التي نعتمد عليها جميعًا
على الإطلاق الذي أصبح عالقًا يوم
الثلاثاء بعد أن علق
في الرياح العاتية وعاصفة رملية
شرسة تسببت في ضعف الرؤية
و  ضعف الملاحة ، مالكها ،
شركة الشحن اليابانية
shoui kizon kk ، يستعد
لدعاوى قضائية من الأطراف المتضررة ، لكنه يقول إن
تركيزهم الرئيسي في هذا
المنعطف الحرج
هو إعادة تعويم السفينة John defterious cnn Abu Dhabi
you